Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Der moderne Fußball, er treibt seine besonderen Blüten und vier davon wollen wir uns jetzt anschauen mit einem Gast, der in Manchester lebt und einem Gast, der in Malaga lebt. Jetzt hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 133. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Ich begrüße zwei Gäste ausnahmsweise mal bei mir im Rasenfunk. Zum einen Hendrik Buchheister, freier Journalist. Er lebt, wie eben schon erwähnt, in Manchester. Bei Twitter twittert er unter h-Buchheister. Servus Hendrik, schön, dass du mal wieder hier bist. Ja, sehr gerne und auch in dieser besonderen Konstellation, dass wir uns verbinden über Landesgrenzen hinweg mit Fabian Pakulat. Ebenfalls freier Journalist, der in Malaga lebt. Ed Rosengartler auf Twitter. Servus Fabian.
Malaga, München, Manchester.
Ja, so hatte ich doch gar nicht drüber nachgedacht. Da hast du völlig recht. Aber da merkt man den gewandten Journalisten im Umgang mit dem Wort, der erkennt die Alliteration sofort. Da gibt es Überschriftenpotenzial. Von München nach Malaga. Und ich reime direkt. Ja, Wahnsinn. Da erkennt man dann den Vater junger Kinder. Hier wird viel Bibi Blocksberg gehört. Da wird auch viel gereimt. Aber wir wollen nicht über Bibi Blocksberg reden, auch nicht über Alliterationen, sondern über vier Vorfälle, die es jeweils in den Ligen bei euch zu beobachten gab und die irgendwie vielleicht dann auch miteinander zusammenhängen weil sie ein ganz gutes Bild davon zeichnen, wohin sich der Fußball im Jahr 2019 entwickelt hat. Wir gehen jetzt einfach mal alle Fälle durch und dann bin ich mal gespannt, was ihr mir dazu zu erzählen habt, denn nicht alles hat man hier in Deutschland so gut mitbekommen. Lasst uns mal in England beginnen, Hendrik. Beim FC Bury, das ist ein Verein, der 1885 gegründet wurde, aktuell in der dritten Liga spielt, bzw. eigentlich muss man sagen, gespielt hat. Was ist denn da passiert?
Genau, und nicht mehr spielt, weil der Verein jetzt vor zwei Wochen von der Liga ausgeschlossen wurde nach 125 Jahren Mitgliedschaft in dieser Football League. Der FC Bury ist ein Verein aus dem Großraum Manchester, also nördlich von Manchester, die schon in der Vergangenheit Finanzprobleme hatten, weil man im Grunde zu viel Geld für Spiele ausgegeben hat, die eben nicht gut genug waren, also der Kader war aufgebläht, es wurden zu hohe Gehälter gezahlt und so weiter. Es gab 2002 schon mal einen Vorfall, als der Verein kurz vor dem Kollaps stand, da wurde Bury dann gerettet, unter anderem durch den Vater von Phil und Gary Neville, der Neville Neville heißt, und damals im Vorstand des Vereins saß, also er hat damals mitgeholfen. Die Probleme haben sich fortgesetzt, man hat aus diesen Problemen offenbar nicht die richtigen Schlüsse gezogen und so kam es, dass dann im Frühjahr, in diesem Frühjahr, Bury aufgestiegen ist, von der vierten Liga in die dritte, also von der League Two in die League One hier in England, und sich dann hinterher herausgestellt hat, dass man sich auch diesen Kader nicht leisten konnte. Also viele Spieler wurden angeblich über Monate nicht bezahlt, Mitarbeiter wurden nicht bezahlt, der Trainer und der Großleiter haben sich im Sommer dann abgesetzt, also haben den Verein verlassen. Und die Liga, die EFL, hat einen Verein gefordert, dass man zu einer bestimmten Frist Nachweise erbringen müsse, dass der Spielbetrieb finanziert werden kann, dass ich dieser Verein finanzieren kann. Da gab es dann mehrere Fristen, die dann zum Teil auch verlängert wurden oder es gab einen weiteren Aufschub. Und diese letzte Frist, da gab es aber keinen Aufschub mehr. Da war die Liga dann relativ streng. Und ich hatte dann ja vor zwei Wochen eine letzte Übernahme. Es gab wohl einen Käufer, der diesen Verein übernehmen wollte und der dem Verein aus seiner misslichen Lage helfen wollte, nachdem diese Übernahme dann recht kurzfristig gescheitert war. Also eineinhalb Stunden vor Ende dieser Deadline hat dann die IFL gesagt, das war's, die fliegt aus der Liga. Also Bury ist jetzt aus dem Liga-Verband ausgeschlossen, damit auch vom Spielbetrieb ausgeschlossen. Bury ist nicht liquidiert. Also es gibt diesen Verein weiterhin. Die spielen jetzt aber nicht. Und die Hoffnung des Vereins und auch der Fans und auch die MPs aus Bury, die sich da sehr stark engagieren, ist, dass man in der neuen Saison in der vierten Liga möglicherweise wieder einsteigt. Das weiß man aber nicht. Aber erstmal ist der Stand so, dass dieser sehr traditionsreiche Verein und auch diese Stadt Bury sehr wichtig ist für die Leute von dort, dass der erstmal nicht mehr spielt und die Zukunft also vollkommen unklar ist.
Also MPs, das sind die Members of Parliament, also die Abgeordneten aus dem Bereich des FC Bury. Du hast jetzt schon gesagt, im Großraum Manchester, ist das dann auch ein Grund dafür, dass es der FC Bury immer so schwer hatte? Also es ist ein sehr traditionsreicher Verein, 1885 gegründet, wie schon angesprochen. Zwei Mal den FA Cup gewonnen, da muss man allerdings schon ganz ans Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts gehen, um sich da dran zu erinnern. 1900 und 1903, das waren die letzten großen Erfolge dieses Vereins. Wurden die erdrückt von den großen Vereinen, die in Manchester selbst sitzen?
Das würde ich so nicht sagen, weil der Verein ja sehr lange existiert hat und sehr lange auch funktioniert. Und die Leute dort sagen, trotz dieser Konkurrenz, so wie natürlich Manchester Night, Manchester City, gibt es uns also irgendwas. Müssen wir richtig gemacht haben. Es ist hier schon so, dass die Konkurrenz insgesamt hier in der Gegend sehr groß ist. Es gibt ja nicht nur die Premier League Clubs, sondern Bolton, auf die wir noch zu sprechen kommen. Leeds ist nicht sehr weit weg. Es gibt noch viele Vereine in der 2. und 3. Liga hier im Großraum. Trotzdem halten sich diese Clubs irgendwie. Das Problem in Bury war eher, dass es dann hier zuletzt zwei Besitzer gab, die offenbar nicht dafür geeignet waren, einen Fußball-Club zu führen und diesen Verein vor die Wand gefahren haben.
Unglaublich. Und es ist zum allerersten Mal, dass die EFL, also der englische Ligenverband, einem Club aus den obersten drei Ligen die Lizenz entziegt. Es gab schon mal jemanden, der seine freiwillig zurückgegeben hat. Das freiwillig würde ich in Anführungszeichen setzen, freiwillig wegen Perspektivlosigkeit in finanzieller Hinsicht. Aber zum allerersten Mal, dass das entzogen wurde. Fabian, ist es denn in Spanien auch so eine Ausnahme, dass so etwas passieren könnte?
Eine Ausnahme würde ich nicht sagen. Es kann schon passieren und es ist letztes Jahr in der zweiten Liga zum Beispiel, dem Zweitligistrius passiert, katalanischer Verein, der im Winter die Spielerlaubnis versagt bekommen hat, weil er seine Zahlungen nicht mehr nachgehen konnte und dann glaube ich jetzt in die vierte spanische Liga zwangsabsteigen musste.
Es ist also kein ganz neues Phänomen. Ich fand die Umstände bei Bury so dramatisch, Hendrik. Deswegen bin ich auch an diesem Fall, also ich hab's gelesen und dann hat mich das zwei Tage beschäftigt und dann hab ich wieder nachgegoogelt und dann hab ich auch einen Text von dir gesehen bei Spiege Online und Freunde hat darüber geschrieben und die ganze Konstellation fand ich irgendwie so irre. Also du hast diesen Verein, du bist Fan dieses Vereins vielleicht schon dein Leben lang und dann hast du, es wird schon kein Spiel ausgetragen, weil die EFL schon sagt, also da müsst ihr uns jetzt erst mal beweisen, dass ihr überhaupt noch irgendwie liquide seid. Dann kommt diese Nachricht, dass jemand bereit ist, den Verein zu kaufen. Die Fans gehen vor Ort ins Stadion, weil es keine Mitarbeiter des Vereins mehr gibt und richten selbst das Stadion hier fürs allererste Spiel, was glaube ich am 8. Spieltag oder so erst stattgefunden hätte. Und dann irgendwann sickert die Nachricht durch, denn der neue potenzielle Käufer schafft es auch nicht, das was in der Vergangenheit da an Schulden und so weiter aufgetäumt würde, überhaupt aufzudrösen. Und deswegen ist es dann doch vorbei. Und ich fand irgendwie diese Zuspitzung, das war fast schon wie aus einem schlechten Film, ehrlich gesagt.
Das war in der Tat so. Und gerade dieser Tag, den du ansprichst, wo die Fans dann mitgeholfen haben, das Stadion sauber zu machen, weil der Verein halt eben das entsprechende, die entsprechende Mitarbeiter nicht mehr hatte. Das war, das war schon sehr besonders. Ich war an diesem Tag selbst auch da und habe gesehen, was da los war. Da waren also 250 bis 300 Freiwillige. Nicht nur Bury-Fans, sondern auch Fans von anderen Vereinen, weil die gesagt haben, oder die erkannt haben, das kann uns genauso passieren. Und es geht hier mehr so darum, dass die Fußballfamilie, um das mal ein bisschen pathetisch auszudrücken, hier zusammenhält, diese 250 bis 200 Leute an diesem Stadion sauber gemacht, in Erwartung, dass am nächsten Samstag möglicherweise das erste Spiel stattfindet, aber auch in dem Wissen, dass es am Abend schon alles vorbei sein kann. Genau, und so kam es dann auch. Es gab diesen interessanten, CNN Sporting Risk hießen die, das ist so eine Sportberatungsfirma, die aber auch, soweit ich das weiß, nur gesagt haben, wir können uns das vorstellen. Und als sie dann in die Bücher geschaut haben und gesehen haben, wie groß die Probleme sind, haben sie gesagt, das können wir nicht machen. Und dann, wie gesagt, kamen wirklich eineinhalb Stunden vor Ablauf dieser Frist, sickerte das durch und die Leute, die haben ja am Stadion gewartet, also es haben sich auch vor dem Stadion die Leute versammelt, um, ja warum eigentlich? Also, weil es war irgendwie klar, da vor Ort passiert erstmal nichts. Es waren halt sehr viele beperrte Teams da.
Man möchte halt in der Gemeinschaft sein zu so einem Moment.
Genau darum ging es, ja genau, und ich finde, das hat total gezeigt, auch wofür dieser Verein steht. Man wollte irgendwie in der Gemeinschaft sein. Es waren dann sehr viele Fans da. Es waren natürlich auch sehr viele Kamerateams und Fernsehteams da. Man hat es dann immer um den Wagen von Sky irgendwie versammelt, wenn dann der Reporter vor Ort seinen kurzen Aufsage gemacht hat und dann gesagt, ja es gibt möglicherweise neue Interessenten, aber genau das weiß man nicht und dann haben alle ein heller Aufregung und genau das weiß man nicht und irgendwann war dann halt klar, dass dann nichts mehr passiert. Es sagen Leute, die mit dieser möglichen Übernahme beschäftigt waren, angeblich gab es noch einen weiteren Interessenten, nachdem dieser erste Versuch gescheitert war. Und angeblich lagen der Liga sogar auch die Unterlagen vor Ablauf der Frist vor, hat die Liga aber offensichtlich nicht mehr überzeugt.
Wenn ich da mal kurz reingerechnen darf, mich würde interessieren, die Eigentümer davor, die quasi den Karren so langsam an die Wand gefahren haben, waren das auch Investoren, waren das Einzelmänner, waren das vielleicht sogar ausländische Investoren?
Nein, das waren Leute aus England, beide im Immobiliengeschäft tätig, was auch zeigt, dass es gar nicht immer den Investor von Übersee braucht, um einen Verein zu ruinieren, sondern dass es auch Leute von vor Ort sehr gut können. Aber ganz offensichtlich hatten die halt kein großes Interesse an dem Verein. Stephen Dale, der letzte Besitzer von Bury und der jetzt noch immer Besitzer ist, hat das sogar offen gesagt in einem Radio-Interview. Ich habe mit Bury eigentlich nichts zu tun. Bevor ich diesen Verein gekauft habe, wusste ich gar nicht, dass es in Bury einen Fußballverein gibt. Und das, finde ich, sagt da schon sehr viel darüber aus, wo da die Probleme liegen.
Da fragt man sich, warum man dann überhaupt einen Verein kaufen muss eigentlich, aber gut.
Der hat den Verein im letzten Dezember für einen Pfund gekauft. Also der Verein wurde halt verramscht und es ging ihm jetzt glaube ich erstmal nicht darum, ein großes Investment zu tätigen, sondern das sagen halt viele Leute, die die Assets dieser Verein halt noch hatte, also unter dem Stadion, halt irgendwie zu verscherbeln und dann da Geld rauszuziehen.
Oh man, oh man. Und bei einer Bemerkung von dir habe ich ein bisschen aufgehäuft, nämlich als du gesagt hast, dass auch Fans anderer Vereine mit dabei waren, das Stadion herzurichten, aus dem Gefühl heraus uns könnte dasselbe passieren. Ist denn die finanzielle Lage bei den Vereinen, vor allem der unteren Spielklassen, so prekär, dass es jetzt wirklich sein könnte, dass der FC Bury einen Reigen eröffnet von mehr Vereinen noch, die ein ähnliches Schicksal erleiden?
Das ist auf jeden Fall das Gefühl und glaube ich auch der Grund dafür, dass das hier in England ein sehr großes Thema in den Medien war, dass Bury und auch Bolton keine Einzelfälle sind, sondern dass die auf strukturelle und grundsätzliche Probleme hinweisen, die es in den unteren Ligen gibt, wo sich die Vereine zum Teil übernehmen, weil sie in die Premier League möchten und das Geld verdienen möchten, das man in der Premier League verdienen kann. Das ist natürlich eher bei Bolton der Fall gewesen als bei Bury. Aber dass es natürlich grundsätzliche Probleme gibt und es gab auch in der Vergangenheit schon Fälle, wo Vereine insorvent gegangen sind oder ganz kurz vor dem Ruin standen. Es war ein Fan zum Beispiel dort von Leeds United, die ja nach dieser Erfolgswelle mit Champions League und so weiter in den 2000ern so einer der ersten großen prominenten Clubs war, die wirklich am Abgrund standen. Und der meinte auch, naja, wir haben noch mit diesem ganzen Mist angefangen, deswegen helfe ich natürlich mit. Und genau, also das ist glaube ich hier schon sehr vielen Leuten klar, dass das Risiko sehr hoch ist, dass das auch bei anderen Vereinen passieren kann.
Eigentlich ja völlig irre. In dem reichsten Fußballmarkt der Welt, auch wenn sich der Reichtum natürlich erst mal auf die oberste Spielklasse bezieht, aber da führt das dann quasi zu einer Furcht oder einem Willen, dass man an diesen Geldreigen beteiligt wird, dass man sich dann verhebt und führt dann eben genau zum Gegenteil. Du kommst nicht in die Premier League und wirst eben beteiligt an diesen wahnsinnigen Geldströmen, die da fließen, sondern du überhebst dich finanziell und das kann im schlimmsten Fall eben zur nicht kompletten Liquidierung des Vereins führen, aber der FC Bury ist jetzt trotzdem sportlich erst mal nicht mehr relevant auf Jahre hinaus. Lass uns dann vielleicht mal gleich bei Bolton weitermachen. Du hast es jetzt ja auch schon angesprochen, dass es ein weiterer Drittligist ist. Da wird jetzt die Stimmung ein bisschen besser, denn die wurden immerhin gerettet. Juhu. Erzähl uns, was war da?
Die wurden immerhin gerettet und das hat sich aber tatsächlich, also die beiden Fälle, Bury und Bolton haben sich zeitgleich abgespielt. Also an dem Tag, an dem Bury aus der Liga ausgeschlossen wurde, stand auch Bolton kurz davor, ausgeschlossen zu werden und das hätte für die dann wahrscheinlich wirklich Liquidierung bedeutet, weil die anders als Bury schon in einem Insolvenzverfahren befanden. Und genau, die wurden an dem Tag aber auch gerettet bzw. am Tag danach. Also da gab es noch einen Aufschub und dann gab es einen Käufer und Bolton wurde übernommen und die spielen jetzt auch weiterhin in der dritten Liga. Bei Bolton war es so, dass der Verein in den 2000ern in der Premier League war, zehn Jahre lang sogar und zum Teil auch international gespielt hat. Also wo man sich als Bayern-Fan vielleicht auch daran erinnern kann, dass die Bolton Wanderers berühmterweise mal Unentschieden in München gespielt haben, worauf dann der berühmte Satz von Karl-Heinz Rummenigge, viel Fußball ist keine Mathematik und Bolton mit Spielern wie Ivan Campo, Yuri Djorkajev, Fernando Hierro, Freddy Bobic, Nikola Anelka, also so mit diesen Top-Namen, die dann am Ende ihrer Karriere noch mal nach Bolton gewechselt sind. Aber auch da hat sich der Verein verhoben und vor allem verhoben, als es eben doch Mathematik auf der finanziellen Seite ging. Also da hat es der Verein verhoben und gerade, als es darum ging eben in der Premier League zu bleiben, hat sich der Verein verhoben, hat viel zu hohe Gehälter gezahlt und nach dem Abstieg 2012 wurde dann auch klar, wie groß die Probleme sind. Also im Jahresabschluss 2013 168 Millionen Pfund Schulden. Und da war dann klar, oh, da ist aber irgendwas in den letzten Jahren gewaltig schiefgelaufen. Und genau, auch Bolton hatte dann einen Besitzer, der sich ganz offensichtlich nicht so sehr um das Wohl des Vereins gekümmert hat, der sich selbst noch berater Honorarer ausgezahlt haben soll, als der Verein schon finanziell am Boden lag. Und auch in der, genau, und Bolton hat in der letzten Saison noch zweite Liga gespielt, also Championship, wo dann zum Teil aber auch Spiele schon nicht mehr stattgefunden haben, weil die Spieler gestreikt haben, weil sie nicht bezahlt wurden, oder weil es da andere Probleme gab. Bolton ist dann in ein Insolvenzverfahren gegangen, was bedeutet, dass der Verein mit 12 Minuspunkten in die neue Saison startet. Bolton hat im Gegensatz zu Bury, die ersten Spiele der Saison, auch gespielt. Es gab da in der Regel 0 zu 5 Niederlagen. Mittlerweile steht Bolton bei, haben immerhin schon einen Unentschieden geholt, stehen sie bei minus 11 Punkten und die werden absteigen. Aber das ist für Fans von Bolton, die Bolton Wanderers vor zwei, drei Wochen gesagt haben, ihr steigt am Ende der Saison ab und spielt in der nächsten Saison wieder in der vierten Liga, dann hätten die das genommen. Weil, wie gesagt, die Alternative wäre gewesen, dass es diesen Verein wirklich nicht mehr gibt.
Man sollte halt doch schon irgendwie auch eine Bisse Ahnung vom Fußballgeschäft mitbringen, wenn man da in irgendeinen Verein einsteigt und einfach nicht völlig nur die Möglichkeiten sehen. Vor allen Dingen wahrscheinlich in England, da kommen schnell die Pfundzeichen in die Augen. Und hey, ich kann rein kaufen und was meine Premier League alles oder auch in den unterliegenden Geld verdienen kann. Aber entweder man sollte sich halt selbst auskennen im Fußballgeschäft oder sich halt dann mit Leuten umgarnieren, die sich halt dann auskennen, die dann eben auch wissen, wie das alles läuft. Weil, ja, sonst geht halt so was schief einfach.
Ja, und das Problem, was man bei beiden Vereinen hat, also sowohl Bury als auch Bolton, ist, dass es eigentlich ein Verfahren gibt von der Liga, das neue Besitzer von Vereinen prüft, bevor sie einen Verein übernehmen können.
Man bekommt auch ein Gefühl dafür, warum die Liga das möchte. Allein an den beiden Beispielen, die wir hier schon besprochen haben.
Ja, genau. Also, eigentlich gibt es, also, formal gibt es Mechanismen, die sowas verhindern wollen. In der Praxis funktionieren diese Mechanismen nicht, weil Ken Anderson, der Besitzer der Bolton Wanderers, hatte in der Vergangenheit mehrere Unternehmen vor die Wand gefahren, war eine Zeit lang sogar, durfte in England keine Geschäfte führen. Dieses Verbot galt nicht mehr, als es in die Bolton Wanderers übernommen hat, aber ich frage mich, wenn es eigentlich ein Verfahren gibt, was verhindern soll, dass unzuverlässige Geschäftsleute einen Fußballverein übernehmen, dann frage ich mich, warum er das durfte und bei Bury war es sogar so, dass Steve Dale, der Besitzer des Vereins, im Dezember für eben diesen einen Pfund gekauft hat, von der Liga gar nicht geprüft wurde. Das hat die Liga sogar eingestanden, mehr oder weniger, dass er eben gar nicht geprüft wurde, bevor er den Verein übernehmen konnte. Das ist eines der Grundprobleme, die dieser ganzen Geschichte zugrunde liegen. Dass diese Sicherheitsmechanismen, die es eigentlich geben sollte, in der Praxis nicht funktionieren.
Ehrlich gesagt auch schwierig. Wenn ich mir das einfach noch mal vorstelle, man kann ja diese ganzen Diskussionen vor dem 50 plus 1 Hintergrund ja auch für Deutschland relevant sein, weil wir hier an vier Beispielen sehen, wie es mal viermal jetzt nicht immer komplett schief gegangen ist, aber es gab jetzt vier interessante Beispiele. Zwei davon haben wir jetzt ja schon mal angesprochen in der jüngeren Vergangenheit, wo man gesehen hat, was passieren kann, wenn eben einzelne Personen mit einer eigenen Agenda über das Wohl und Wehe eines Vereins entscheiden. Und vor diesem Hintergrund ist es ja dann auch für Deutschland relevant. Und wenn ich mir dann aber vorstelle, dass dann der natürliche Reflex ist, dass auch die DFL sagen könnte, ja Moment, wir führen einfach ein Prüfverfahren ein, nur ehrliche Kaufmänner mit Ahnung dürfen einen Verein übernehmen, dann stelle ich mir schon wieder die Frage, passt das überhaupt mit EU-Wettbewerbsrecht zusammen? Das ist jetzt dann in Großbritannien nicht mehr so relevant bald. Aber das ist ja alles gar nicht so einfach zu händen. Und du legst halt im Grunde dann die Verantworter dann in die Hände der Liga, die aber ja auch eine eigene Agenda verfolgt. Also wenn die jetzt eben zum Beispiel gar nicht mehr überprüft haben, ob der neue Besitzer des FC Bury dann auch wirklich jemand ist, der diesen Verein übernehmen sollte, dann tut die Liga das ja nicht aus Faulheit, sondern weil man eben eigene Interessen hat. Man möchte, dass der Verein gerettet wird. Man will dann vielleicht auch manchmal nicht so genau hinschauen, weil man einfach froh ist, dass man nicht diese Negativgeschichte hat, die es jetzt eben dann trotzdem gab. Aber das hatte man ja damals noch gehofft, dass man das abwenden können würde.
Ich wollte nur sagen, was die Rolle der Liga angeht, viele Fans sagen oder so, der Gesamteindruck ist, dass die Liga vor allem ein Interesse hat, dass die Spiele stattfinden, dass die Liga vor allem Spiele organisiert und bei allem anderen nicht so genau hinschaut.
Ja und ich denke einfach, die Gefahr bei solchen Prüfverfahren oder wie auch immer, ist ja auch, wie man sich bei der FIFA sieht, dass hier auch dann am Endeffekt irgendwelche Leute entscheiden und dann ist es doch einfach mal Fakt so, dass man halt dann auch vielleicht noch ein Sonderabkommen erzählt, dass da vielleicht ein oder andere Briefumschlag noch über den Tisch geht und dann ist das Prüfverfahren dann doch okay. Also das ist sehr gefährlich, glaube ich, und ändert eigentlich dann auch nichts an der Tatsache, dass dann trotzdem mysteriöse Investoren dann rein grätschen können in Vereine. Vor allen Dingen in Traditionsvereine, da tut es ja am meisten weh an einem Endeffekt.
Ja genau, Bolton Wanderers 1874 als Christchurchs FC gegründet. Also da sprechen wir auch über ein Urgestein des englischen Fußballs. Eine andere Frage, die ich mir noch gestellt habe, Hendrik, als du das mal aufgedröset hast, wie es jetzt zur vorübergehenden Rettung bei Bolton kam, waren eben diese Schulden, die ja so immens hoch waren, wie sieht denn das Lizensierungsverfahren in England aus? Also ist die Liga dann auch überrascht davon, dass da auf einmal der neue Besitzer sagt, oder nach dem Abstieg dann offen wird, wie viele Schulden man eigentlich hat? Hat die Liga das gewusst? Wie kann man das jetzt im Vergleich zu den deutschen Lizensierungsgegebenheiten vergleichen?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Das kann ich dir ehrlich gesagt nicht im Detail erklären. Aber was ich sagen kann, ist, dass die Liga dann eingreift, wenn es ein Vorfall gibt, der einer Insolvenz gleicht oder in die Richtung geht und dann eben Punkte abzieht und das war bei sowohl bei Bury als auch, wie ich schon angesprochen habe, bei Bolton der Fall vor dieser Saison. Also beide Vereine sind mit 12 Minuspunkten die Saison gestartet, weil es bei Bury so eine Art Rettungsplan gab, um die Schulden abzutragen und Bolton halt tatsächlich in die Insolvenz gegangen ist. Also denen wurden Punkte abgezogen, aber sie durften weiter mitspielen.
Und wie würdest du jetzt dann die Aussichten für die Bolton Wanderers beschreiben? Weil die Geschichte ist ja jetzt nicht zu Ende. Es ist nur quasi das schlimmstmögliche Ende verschoben worden oder vielleicht auch verhindert worden. Also man wird sehr wahrscheinlich absteigen, weil man eben immer noch bei minus elf Punkten steht, hast du ja schon beschrieben. Was glaubst du, wie die Chancen stehen, dass dieser Verein, der ja wirklich auch lange Teil, also elf Jahre der Premier League war und seinerseits eben auch auf eine lange Historie zurückblickt, dann vor allem auch in der zweiten Liga, dass der noch länger Bestand haben kann oder droht, dass wir uns in einem Jahr über Bolton unterhalten und dann das passiert ist, was jetzt der FC Bury erleben musste?
Ja, also ich habe den Angriff, dass das droht latent und dass das einfach eine Geschichte ist, die nicht von heute auf morgen, nur weil jetzt ein neuer Besitzer eingestiegen ist, sich dieses Problem löst. Also das wird seine Zeit dauern und natürlich bleibt Bolton weiter ein Pflegefall. Die sind jetzt erstmal von der Intensivstation runter, aber ich glaube, das wird noch eine Weile dauern, bis man da wirklich von Sicherheit sprechen kann. Über diese neuen Besitzer, diese Football-Ventures heißen die, weiß man nicht sehr viel. Die Leute in Bolton sagen, erstmal ist alles besser als unser vorheriger Besitzer. Der Ex-Schlagzeuger von Pink Floyd ist bei diesen neuen Besitzern beteiligt, was natürlich in der britischen Presse auch entsprechend gewürdigt wurde. Ich glaube, realistisch ist das, wie gesagt, Bolton Wanderers absteigen. Wir haben jetzt eine Mannschaft mit sehr vielen Jugendspielern hier hochgezogen worden und sehr vielen Leuten, die man am letzten Tag der Transferfrist noch beschaffen konnte. Also es ist so eine sehr hastig zusammengestellte Mannschaft, mit der man jetzt den Spielbetrieb bestreitet. Und ich glaube, der Weg in die Zukunft könnte sein, dass man sich versucht, jetzt zu konsolidisieren und natürlich auch auf dem Platz vielleicht ein bisschen Grundlagen zu schaffen für eine Mannschaft, die in der neuen Saison in der vierten Liga sich dort etabliert, sich dann nach und nach wieder nach oben arbeitet.
Aber da muss ich jetzt doch nochmal nachhaken. Also es hat jetzt übernommen, die Football Benches Limited, die ist irgendwie seit 2019 eingetragen. Und man weiß aber jetzt nicht, wer dahinter steht. Wie kann denn das überhaupt sein?
Na doch, man weiß, dass das Leute von vor Ort sind. Diese Football Benchers wurden auch, weil du sagst eingetragen seit 2019, also die wurden gegründet, um die Bolton Wanderers zu kaufen und zu retten. Aber was genau deren langfristige Strategie ist, das ist glaube ich auch noch nicht so ganz klar.
Ein Rettungszusammenschluss. Dann wechseln wir mal das Land und schauen mal nach Spanien. Da haben wir nämlich auch zwei interessante Vorfälle in den letzten Wochen erlebt. Zum einen, ich würde mal als Arbeitstitel drüber setzen, Fabian Fußballmanager 2019-2020. Und nämlich bei Almería in der zweiten Liga ist ein Saudi-Arabischer Schaich eingestiegen. Turki Al-Shaik am 2. August. Und man würde ja meinen, 2. August, das ist sehr, sehr spät, vor Schließung des Transferfensters, da kann es nicht mehr so arg viel passieren.
Da geht es nochmal richtig zur Sache. Der Junge, der ist nämlich noch relativ jung, der Schaich, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, der hat den Verein umgekrempelt innerhalb von 25, 30 Tagen. Und zwar ziemlich brachial. Ich glaube, es ging erstmal los, da sämtliche Vorbereitungstestspiele abgesagt worden sind, der Trainer wurde entlassen.
Der erst in der Sommerpause kam. Also der hat noch kein einziges Pflichtspiel für Almería trainieren lassen dürfen und war trotzdem schon...
Ich glaube, ein Testspiel hat er noch machen dürfen, aber das war es dann auch schon. Und dann hat der Schaich als einer seiner ersten Amtshandlungen dann auch angewiesen, dass sämtliche Leihspieler eigentlich sofort zurückgeschickt werden, außer es besteht eine Kaufoption, denn seine Idee war, entweder er will Spieler haben, die ihm im Verein gehören oder wo er zumindest die Chance hat, die dann am Ende der Saison zu kaufen. Da mussten dann viele Spieler auch noch kurzfristig vom Hof gejagt werden. Da hat mich auch überrascht, dass sowas ging, weil diese Leute eigentlich auch schon gültige Verträge hatten, aber wenn man einen neuen Vereinsboss hat, dann gelten diese Verträge dann eben dann anscheinend nicht mehr. Und da gab es ja auch die kuriose Geschichte von einem Stürmer, der dann beim FC Malaga gelandet ist und dort dann auch kurzfristig nochmal dann vom Hof gejagt worden ist. Also zweimal innerhalb dieses Sommers der Arme. Naja, und dann hat er sich Spieler geholt und unter anderem mit 8,8 Millionen Euro den teuersten Transfer, ein überraschender Transfer, wie ich finde, mit Arvin Apia ein englisches Talent mit 20 Jahren von Nottingham Forest gekauft, an dem angeblich auch Manchester United drin war. Und das hat der Schalke von Almería gleich richtig gefeiert und hat bei Twitter dann quasi ein Foto von dem Spieler abgebildet und hat ihn wieder runtergeschrieben, zufisant, ja, hey, Manchester United, sorry, aber wir haben euch jetzt dieses Talent mal eben schnell weggeschnappt.
Also er ist auch sehr, wie soll ich sagen, er ist sehr leise reingegrätscht.
Also er ist 38 Jahre alt, also nur falls jetzt Leute bei diesem Verhalten dachten, das macht eher ein 15-Jähriger, nein, 38 ist er, aber halt immer noch jung im Fußball-Investoren-Geschäft, wenn man das so möchte. Wie kam es denn zu der Übernahme? Warum war denn Almería überhaupt zu haben für, was ich gelesen habe, 20 Millionen Euro, was jetzt auch nicht der teuerste aller Preise ist für einen Verein?
Nee, da denkt man selber, einmal diesen Euro-Checkpot gewinnen, dann kann ich mir auch einen spanischen Zweitligist kaufen. Neben den 20 Millionen gibt es natürlich auch noch diverse Schulden, Verbindlichkeiten, die man dann quasi mit übernimmt. Wie hoch die genau sind, kann ich bei Almería nicht sagen, aber ich denke, die sind auch mindestens im zweistelligen Millionenbereich anzusiedeln. Und dann hat er eben noch mal im Sommer 20 Millionen investiert in Spieler und Trainer und so weiter und sorgt weiter für Furore, will die Fans auf seine Seite holen, indem er glaube ich bisher in jedem Testspiel und auch Heimspiel einen Audi verlost. Er macht leider so lustige Geschichten, hat jetzt auch vorgeschlagen, das hat übrigens das Malagas Schreiche auch mal versucht, das Vereinslogo zu ändern in ein Wappen mit einem Löwen, das ist ja in der arabischen Welt ein gern gesehenes Tier, sagen wir es mal so.
Jetzt verstehe ich, warum auch die Sechziger einen Investor aus diesem Bereich haben.
Unser Schreich vom FC Malaga hat auch mal versucht, den Löwen als neues Vereins-Tiersymbol oder wie auch immer man das nennen möchte, zu installieren. Aber da sind natürlich die Fanwellen hochgeschlagen, das war ganz klar, das sind ja auch Traditionsvereine in Spanien und die wollen solche Sachen nicht mit sich machen lassen. Diese Scheichs habe ich so das Gefühl, vor allem die hier in Spanien, in dem Fall von Almería und Malaga zumindest, gehen sehr unbedarft an die Sache ran und haben so nach wie vor die Meinung, glaube ich, oder die Einstellung, die sie wahrscheinlich auch in ihrem Heimatland haben, dass sie machen und tun können, was sie möchten. Sie haben es ein bisschen schwer, sich dann an die hiesigen Regeln zu halten. Bei Almería wird man jetzt erstmal sehen, wie es läuft. Jetzt ist noch große Euphorie Anfang, der Sessorstart ist geglückt, 10 von 12 Punkten. Im Moment ist dann natürlich Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen, beziehungsweise da ist natürlich eine große Euphorie, weil er ausgebrochen ist. Wie es dann laufen kann, schlechterweise, ist dann das Gegenbeispiel hier bei unserem FC Malaga, bei dem es nach Hurei Investitionen am Anfang und einem tollen sportlichen Erfolg auch ganz steil bergab ging und im Moment die Gefahr sogar ziemlich groß ist. Dass was ähnliches passiert, was den 60er-Löwen passiert ist.
Ja, das ist immer so der Zyklus. Jemand Neues kommt rein, wirft mit Geld um sich, also nur um das kurz mal mit Zahlen zu unterfüttern. Es gab 23 Zugänge jetzt in diesem kurzen Zeitfenster, in dem der Scheich das Sagen hatte und 24 Abgänge. Also einmal komplett alles durchgetauscht. Deswegen auch Fußballmanager 2019, 2020, so wie ich es jetzt benannt habe, dieses Segment. Jetzt kennt man Almería ja aber als Zweitligisten, der aber auch einige Jahre in der ersten Liga gespielt hat. Und die Frage hast du mir noch nicht so ganz beantwortet. Woher kommt es, dass der Verein in diese Schuldensituation gelandet ist? Hat es dann auch mit Abstieg und sich verhoben beim Wiederaufstieg zu tun? Oder wie kam es dazu?
Es ist allgemein ganz schwer für viele Vereine, die in der ersten Liga waren und absteigen, wenn sie nicht im ersten Jahr sofort wieder aufsteigen, dann die finanzielle Balance zu schaffen. Dazu kommt natürlich auch noch, dass Almería so ein bisschen abgeschottet in Spanien liegt. Da ist keine große Industrie, da ist nicht viel Tourismus, da ist allgemein nicht so viel Geld vorhanden. Das macht die Sache natürlich noch mal deutlich schwerer. Die spanische Liga hat so ein System implantiert vor ein paar Jahren, dass jeder Absteiger aus der ersten Liga im ersten Jahr finanzielle Unterstützung erhält und zwar nicht ohne. Das kann auch eine einmalige Zahlung sein von 20 Millionen Euro. Oder auf zwei Saisons verteilt jeweils 10 Millionen Euro in der ersten Abstiegssaison, 10 Millionen Euro in der zweiten Abstiegssaison. Und was viele Mannschaften machen, ist dann, wie auch Malaga zum Beispiel dieses Jahr oder letztes Jahr, die 20 Millionen Euro sofort zu nehmen, um dort diese hohen Kosten von der ersten Liga einigermaßen aufzufangen, trotz noch einen guten Kader zu haben. Wenn dann aber nicht der sofortige Wiederaufstieg gelingt, dann hast du große Probleme. Dann fehlen dir 20 Millionen und du hast wahrscheinlich noch einen Kader, der viel zu teuer ist und den du ordentlich ausrupfen musst. Deswegen tun sich auch viele Traditionsvereine in Spanien schwer, wieder aufzusteigen. Saragossa ist ein Beispiel. Die waren vor zehn Jahren oder so Standard, Erste Liga ist Mittelfeld, auch mal europäisch ambitioniert. Die krebsen jetzt auch seit vielen Jahren in der zweiten Liga rum und kommen nicht wirklich weg vom Fleck. Bei Almería kommt die Geschichte dazu, dass das Umfeld einfach auch nicht so reich ist. Und dann musst du schon jedes Jahr schauen, wie du irgendwie in einem Wettbewerbssegentrader zusammenkommst.
Sag mal, Hendrik, 20 Millionen als Parachuting-Payment, also als finanziellen Fallschirm für einen Absteiger, was sind denn da die Dimensionen in der zweiten englischen Liga?
Ja genau, diese Parachuting-Payments gibt es halt hier auch. Die laufen, je nachdem, wie lange ein Verein davor in der Premier League war, laufen die über zwei oder drei Saisons. Das System wurde vor ein paar Jahren umgestellt. Und die genauen Zahlen habe ich gerade nicht im Kopf.
Bewegt man sich da auch so ungefähr in dieser Range? Also die genauen Zahlen, sind da dann auch pro Verein unterschiedlich?
Genau, ja, ich würde das mal annehmen. Das trägt natürlich so ein bisschen dazu bei, dass das so ein bisschen so ein beschlossenes System ist, und dass die Vereine, die aus der Premier League absteigen, dann relativ schnell wieder die Chance haben, aufzusteigen. Und das ist im Grunde so eine erweiterte Premier League von den Premier League-Vereinen plus drei, vier, fünf Clubs, die halt eben diese Parachute-Premies noch haben, die dann relativ gute Chancen haben, wieder aufzusteigen. Und wie wir aber auch gerade schon gesagt haben, wenn man dann eben nicht aufsteigt und plötzlich diese Zahlungen wegbrechen und man aber einen überteuerten Kader hat, dann die Chancen natürlich auch groß sind, dass man komplett abschmiert.
Ich habe es jetzt gerade mal nachgeguckt. Also man begann 2011, gab es die Parachute-Premies zum ersten Mal. Da ging es noch bei 10,5 Millionen Pfund los, bis hin dann hat sich dann gesteigert. Und jetzt in der letzten Saison sind wir gelandet, Huddersfield hat 42 Millionen Pfund bekommen, West Brom 34,9 Millionen Pfund und Stoke und Swansea genauso. Also das ist inzwischen die Dimension, in der man in England gelandet ist. Fabian, wie wird denn das jetzt aufgenommen? Klar, erst freut man sich, dass der Verein einen neuen Investor hat. Dann freut man sich über viele neue Spieler. Ja, wir haben Manchester United einen Stürmer weggekauft. Aber gleichzeitig gibt es ja auch schon die Negativbeispiele. Wir werden ja auch gleich noch mit Malaga noch über eins sprechen. Ist denn die Reaktion im Umfeld in Spanien jetzt beim Verein selbst, bei den Fans und auch in der landesweiten Presse, wie sind die Reaktionen da?
Die sind schon sehr unterschiedlich. Und da ist schon eine große Skepsis da. Man hat, wie gesagt, vom Nachbarn aus Malaga, wir sind hier 200 Kilometer weit weg, das Beispiel vorgelebt, was da danach alles passieren kann. Und es ist in Spanien schon öfter so was in die Richtung passiert und dementsprechend ist man schon auch gewarnt. Aber wenn du natürlich ein Standard, sag ich jetzt mal Almería-Fan bist, der eigentlich gewohnt ist, immer normalerweise die zweite Liga zu spielen, die Ausflüge in der ersten Liga, die waren schon sehr überraschend, sagen wir es mal so, dass es für das ganze Umfeld und so weiter zu klein ist. Und da ist natürlich schon eine Euphorie da, dass die sagen, jetzt könnte es aber mal richtig abgehen bei uns und vielleicht kriegen wir ein neues Stadion und vielleicht kriegen wir immer ein paar Jahre richtig guten Fußball zu sehen. Und das werden wir dann nie vergessen. Aber wie gesagt, es ist ein ganz schmaler Grad. Man kann so einen Verein ganz schnell kaputt machen, runterwirtschaften und am Ende bleibt ganz viel Schutt und Asche übrig. Und dementsprechend ist die Skepsis auf jeden Fall da, weil man eben auch viele andere Beispiele schon erlebt hat.
Dann lass doch jetzt mal über Malaga sprechen, wo du ja auch allein wegen deines Wohnortes sehr tief drin bist. Da gab es den Hashtag OkazakiDay. Erklär uns doch mal kurz, was ist da jetzt denn schon wieder passiert bei Malaga?
Also Malaga ist ja eigentlich seit dieser furiosen Champions League Saison 2013, da ging es ganz steil bergab und alles begann damals mit dem sogenannten Monreal Day. Daher kommt auch der Okazaki Day. Der Scheich hatte dann seine Lust verloren am investieren, fand sich von UEFA und FIFA betrogen und musste dann eben oder hat dem Verein mehr oder weniger sich selbst überlassen und gesagt, ihr kommt jetzt ohne mein Geld zurecht und dementsprechend mussten viele Spiele verkauft werden. Unter anderem in einer Winterpause, ich glaube, das müsste dann so 2013, 2014 gewesen sein, am letzten Tag um 11.00 Uhr oder um 23.59 Uhr, dann eben Nacho Monreal links Verteidiger Spanien zu Arsenal und noch verkauft werden. Und dementsprechend haben die Fans den Monreal Day genannt. Und jetzt gab es den Okazaki Day. Und diese Geschichte ist leider alles andere als rühmlich, denn man hat diesen Spieler eigentlich erst im Juli unter Vertrag genommen. Der war vereinslos, hatte viele Angebote. Wir kennen ihn alle aus Mainz und Stuttgarter Zeit, japanischer Nationalspieler. Und das war natürlich der Clou für den FC Malaga, so einen Spieler noch mal zu bekommen, obwohl er 33 ist. Aber für die zweite Liga Spaniens wäre es trotzdem eine Wahnsinn zur Pflichtung gewesen. Genau, und dort gut verdient, ist ja auch Meister geworden mit denen und so weiter. Genau, ja, und dann hat man aber nicht hinbekommen für diesen Spiel eine Spielberechtigung zu bekommen. Das liegt schlicht und ergreifend daran, dass das Budget des FC Malaga von letztes Jahr 29 Millionen auf jetzt 9,9 Millionen runtergegangen ist. Und die Liga gesagt hat, okay, ihr habt diesen Spieler unter Vertrag genommen, das ist zwar schön, aber ihr könnt ihn erst einschreiben, wenn ihr euer Gehaltsgefühl anpasst, dementsprechend müsst ihr noch Spieler verkaufen und so weiter. Das hat nicht geklappt und obwohl der Schaich in einem großen Interview, er äußert sich ja nicht wirklich oft offiziell, zumindest gegenüber der Presse in seinem Twitter-Account öfter, hat auf jeden Fall noch am 14. August groß angekündigt, er wird alles auf die Reihe bekommen, sie arbeiten hart an Lösungen, Spieler werden verkauft und es wird alles gut. Und plötzlich gab es dann am 2. September, dem letzten Transfertag horrende Nachrichten aus den Katakomben des Stadions La Rosalia zu hören. Da war dann am Nachmittag schon zu hören, Oh, Oh, Okazaki und auch José Rodríguez, den hatte man auch unter Vertrag genommen, auch X Mainzer. Ja, die kriegen wahrscheinlich gar keine Spielberechtigung. Und ja, dann gab es ganz wilde Stunden. Im Endeffekt hat es dann dazu geführt, dass der Vertrag mit Okazaki wieder aufgelöst werden musste. Und ich glaube, er hat es genauso geschafft, wie der Trainer von Almería, dass er nur ein Testspiel hat mitmachen können, letztlich beim FC Malaga.
Okay, der Montreal Day und der Okazaki Day. Also der arme Okazaki, inzwischen ist er bei Huesca gelandet. Und da durfte er jetzt fünf Minuten jetzt immerhin mal ran. Also für ihn persönlich ging es dann immerhin weiter. Und du hast ja gerade schon das Beispiel genannt, das Spiel ist der von Almería zum Malaga gekommen ist, den ein ähnliches Schicksal erlitten hat. Wie kann man denn das einschätzen, dass wir jetzt hier über zwei Scheich-Investoren sprechen? Ist das stellvertretend für die Liga in Spanien? Sind das jetzt Ausnahmen? Ist das ein Zufall?
Es ist meiner Meinung nach keine wirkliche Ausnahme. Ich glaube, die Scheichs, vor allem die ganz bekannten, hier aus Paris und Manchester City, das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Liga. Aber die Geschichten, die hier so in Spanien laufen, sind sehr kurios. Es gibt noch die Geschichte oder beziehungsweise einen großen Investor, der ist zwar kein Scheich, aber ist ein reicher Mensch aus Malaysia, dieser Peter Lim von Valencia. Dort gibt es auch ganz derbe Probleme, obwohl die immerhin die Champions-League-Qualifikation geschafft haben. Aber da hat es im Sommer auch richtig gebrodelt. Trainersportdirektor wollten gehen, weil man sich nicht an irgendwelche Vereinbarungen gehalten hat. Es ist eine ganz, ganz gefährliche Geschichte hier in Spanien mit den Investoren, mit ausländischen Investoren. Da hat man eigentlich nicht so wirklich gute Erfahrungen machen können. Man hat mit Real Madrid natürlich das andere Beistil, dass man mit Florentino Pérez, einem Bauunternehmer hat, der das Ganze, sagen wir es mal so, sportlich sehr erfolgreich managt. Aber mit diesen ausländischen Investoren hat es in Spanien bisher noch nicht so ganz geklappt. Und na ja, man ist in Spanien eigentlich schon immer so, dass man ausländischen Investoren die Türen weit offen macht und dass man sagt, komm mal her und lass mal dein Geld da. Und am Anfang das Ganze sehr positiv betrachtet. Und dort wird auch mal gerne ein Auge zugedrückt. Auch bei der Geschichte von Almería. Die haben deutlich größeres Budget als der FC Malaga zum Beispiel, obwohl sie es eigentlich faktisch gar nicht haben könnten. Und wenn dann aber sich nicht an die Regeln gehalten wird, wie zum Beispiel im Fall vom FC Malaga, dann wird es natürlich auch eng. Und dann hat die Liga natürlich auch, oder will zumindest versuchen, mit verschiedenen Richtlinien dann verschiedene krummen Geschäfte zu verhindern. Und beim FC Malaga ist es zum Beispiel jetzt so gewesen, dass am letzten Transfertag, glaube ich, nur 14 Profis unter Vertrag standen. Und das natürlich viel zu wenig für so eine Saison. Denn ich glaube, du musst pro Spiel mindestens sieben oder acht Profis drin haben. Und dass du mal den einen oder anderen verletzt und so. Also es wird schon richtig eng. Und man hat dem FC Malaga dann nur gestattet, Spieler zu verkaufen für den Mindestlohn, der bei 80.000 Euro im Jahr liegt. Und da konnten dann noch kurzfristig drei Spieler zumindest gekauft werden. Also wir haben jetzt 17 Profis beim FC Malaga. Mehr ging nicht. Und ja, dementsprechend müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir diese so hinbekommen. Geschichte im Mindestlohn gibt es noch ein interessantes Detail von Okazaki. Der Spieler hätte beim FC Malaga mit Sicherheit nicht so viel verdient wie bei Leicester City, aber ich sage jetzt mal ein bisschen unter einer Million Euro wäre wahrscheinlich sein Gehalt gelegen. Er hat tatsächlich auch, weil er sehr begeistert war vom Verein, vom Umfeld war, hat dem Verein angeboten, er würde jetzt in diesem Jahr für den Mindestlohn von 80.000 Euro spielen. Wahrscheinlich, weil er finanziell das auch gar nicht nötig hätte. Da hat aber dann die Liga eingegriffen und es gibt eine Regelung hier in Spanien, die ich sehr kurios finde und die ganz vielen Zweitligisten zu schaffen macht. Wenn man einen Spieler holt, zum Beispiel aus der ersten Liga oder ihn auch ausleitet, dann darf dieser Spieler nicht weniger verdienen als 50% des Gehaltes des Vorjahres. Das heißt, im Fall von Okazaki, ich weiß nicht, wie viel er bei Leicester verdient hat, aber wahrscheinlich 2 Millionen, 3 Millionen, weiß ich nicht, wie viel Pfund. Das heißt, beim FC Malaga darf er einfach nicht weniger verdienen als, ich sag jetzt mal, 1 Millionen oder 800.000 oder 900.000 Euro. Und alles andere wird sonst angesehen als, ja, linkes Geschäft oder der kriegt die Bezahlungen schwarz und so weiter und so fort. Man möchte sich da so ein bisschen schützen und dementsprechend konnten Spieler wie Okazaki dann auch gar nicht für den Mindestlohn spielen, selbst wenn sie es gewollt hätten. Es gibt auch einen vereinslosen Torwart aus der zweiten Liga, der beim FC Malaga für den Mindestlohn spielen möchte. Auch der hat ein zu hohes Gehalt letztes Jahr gehabt und dem wird die Spielberechtigung verweigert, obwohl er gesagt hat, mir egal, ich will einfach nur kicken, ich will nicht arbeitslos sein. Und da sagt die spanische Liga, nur 50 Prozent maximal geben wir runter, was dein Vorjahresgehalt anbelangt, sonst geben wir dir eben keine Spielberechtigung. Und das ist natürlich für Vereine wie dem FC Malaga dieses Jahr oder sämtlichen Zweitligisten ein großes Problem, dann gute Spiele zu bekommen, wenn man eben diesen Spieler mindestens 50 Prozent des Vorjahresgehalts zahlen muss.
Bei Almería haben wir jetzt eben einen Saudi-Arabischen-Scheich. Der Scheich von Malaga kommt aus Katar, hat auch damals, als er es übernommen hat, für einen korportierten Preis von 36 Millionen Euro, das war im Jahr 2010, auch gesagt, er macht das durchaus in Antizipation der kommenden Weltmeisterschaft und dass er hofft, dass da dann das Interesse am Fußball entsprechend steigt, dass sich dieses Investment für ihn lohnt. Weiß man denn, was dieser Scheich jetzt bei Malaga mit Malaga erreichen möchte? Also geht es da um Prestige? Sprechen wir hier über sehr reiche Menschen, die das als eine Art Spielzeug sehen, so ein bisschen, wie es ja den Anschein macht in Almería. Wie würdest du das einordnen bei Malaga?
Ich habe meine Zweifel, Max, weil der Scheich eigentlich immer mit Malaga Champions League spielen wollte und einer der großen Clubs in Spanien werden wollte, sich etablieren wollte zu den Top-Clubs Europas. Und davon spricht er nach wie vor. Und inzwischen ist die Situation ja völlig anders und es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, über solche Geschichten zu sprechen. Und er hat meines Erachtens dann sich auch selbst widersagt oder seinen Zielen selbst widersagt, wenn man überlegt, dass er innerhalb von eineinhalb, zwei Jahren, nachdem er eingestiegen ist, den Verein immerhin ins Viertelfinale Champions League gebracht hat. Nicht mit Investitionen, die zum Beispiel Paris Saint-Germain seit Jahren versucht oder Manchester City lange versucht hat. Also der hat innerhalb wirklich von kurzer Zeit einen sportlichen Erfolg gehabt und daran hat er nicht festgehalten. Das ist dann für mich schon auch so ein Beleg dafür, dass da irgendwas nicht so ganz stimmt mit den Aussagen und dem, was ich eigentlich mache. Also wenn ich mir wie gesagt überlege, was da eben Paris oder Manchester City schon reingebuttert haben, dann haben wir über die Gruppenphase zu überstehen der Champions League. Und dann hatte man den Verein eigentlich innerhalb von eineinhalb, zwei Jahren schon da, wo man ihn haben wollte. Und diesem Ziel wurde dann eben nicht weiterverfolgt, sondern einfach nur noch jedes Jahr die Gruppenjuwelen verkauft, sprich die besten Spieler verkauft, um überleben zu können. Und so ging es einfach in der Tabelle runter in der ersten Liga. Und dann war es zwangsweise jetzt der Abstieg in die zweite Liga. Und im Moment läuten die Alarmglocken so groß, dass man eben auch davon ausgehen muss, dass wenn nicht bald finanzielle Mittel wieder in den Verein kommen, auf welche Art und Weise auch immer, dann kann das auch ein Beispiel Reos werden, dass der dann einfach im Dezember einfach seine Gehälter nicht mehr zahlen kann und der von einem Zwangsabsteigen muss, dann in die vierte Liga, wie es eben Reos passiert ist, oder wie es dann auch wahrscheinlich ein so ähnliches Beispiel war, glaube ich, auch bei den Sechzigern, die dann eben dann auch runter mussten. Also von daher stimmen die Aussagen, nicht ganz mit dem überein, was er so durchzieht.
Das ist der Fußball im Jahr 2019. Hendrik, Fabian, müsstet ihr nicht eigentlich inzwischen Wirtschaftsjournalisten sein und gar keine Sportjournalisten mehr? Ist das nicht eigentlich das eigentliche Feld, auf dem der Fußball inzwischen ausgetragen wird? Hendrik?
Ja, natürlich. Das ist zumindest ein immer größerer Teil. Und man merkt es an diesen Geschichten wie Bury Bolton oder die spanischen Beispiele, die wir gesprochen haben. Und natürlich spielt es aber auch, der Name Manchester City ist ja gefallen, spielt ja da auch eine ganz große Rolle, dass man ja Manchester City längst nicht mehr nur sportlich bewerten kann, sondern auch mit all dem, was da eben drum herum passiert.
Wird es denn vor Ort auch so gemacht oder ist es so eine deutsche Sicht auf diese Dinge, eben weil es hier noch ein 50 plus 1 gibt und eben auch die Debatten darum?
Unterschiedlich würde ich sagen. Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Leute schon ein Gespür dafür kriegen, dass gerade in der Premier League und auch in den Ligen drunter vieles, in eine sehr problematische Richtung läuft und nicht von ungefähr fliegen jedes Wochenende sehr viele Engländer nach Deutschland, um sich in Deutschland-Spiele anzugucken, weil man natürlich schon das wertschätzt, dass natürlich die Atmosphäre im Stadion noch eine andere ist, aber dieses Business-Modell auch anders läuft. Also dieses 50 plus 1, was in Deutschland zunehmend unter Druck gerät, ist das, wo viele Englisch-Fans zumindest sagen, das ist eigentlich ein erstrebenswertes Modell. Und was Manchester City angeht, das ist lustigerweise, wird das zunehmend diskutiert, seitdem die sehr erfolgreich sind. Also gerade nach dem, dieses FA Cup-Finale zuletzt gegen Watford, was sie 6-0 gewonnen haben, also 6-0 sollte normalerweise kein Pokalfinale ausgehen, das war nochmal so ein Punkt, wo dann plötzlich das sehr stark thematisiert wurde, ist dann eigentlich gut, was da passiert und woher kommt das Geld und was steckt eigentlich hinter diesem Investment aus Abu Dhabi und was sind eigentlich die Ziele. Also das wird zunehmend thematisiert.
Aber ist das nicht ein bisschen spät? Also kann man das jetzt noch zurückdrehen?
Nee, zurückdrehen kann man es nicht. Es geht dann mehr um darum, wie man das deutet und wie man ein Verständnis dafür schafft, was da möglicherweise hintersteht und was die Absichten sind.
Ich denke schon auch, dass der Fußball im Moment schon so eine Blase aufbaut, die irgendwann mal platzen wird. Das kann ja nicht ewig so weitergehen, meiner Meinung nach zumindest. Dass man irgendwann, weiß ich nicht, 400, 500 Millionen für einen Trupp Spieler zahlen muss. Also irgendwann muss diese Blase doch einfach mal platzen. Ich habe überhaupt nichts gegen Investoren, aber es ist schon immer wieder erstaunlich, dass man sich dann einfach dem Sportlichen dann weniger zuwenden muss, bei einigen Freien zumindest, und dann sich über solche Geschichten unterhalten muss. Und dass man einfach überhaupt solche Regelungen wie Prüfverfahren oder Gehaltsgrenze und solche Geschichten einfach irgendwie, dass man das einfach überwachen muss. Es ist eine ganz gefährliche Krux und dann klatschen sich die Vereine die Trikots voll mit Sponsoren und der Fanclub Coca-Cola macht irgendwie eine Aktion da und so. Also das ist alles schwer. Kann mir das mal jemand erklären bitte, ich habe es immer noch nicht probiert.
Also die Choreo vom Fanclub Deutsche Nationalmannschaft powered by irgendwas, bei Zucker mit Zucker, hätte eigentlich Vollgas lauten sollen über München, Frankfurt nach Rom oder keine Ahnung. Nee, irgendwie. Also der Slogan war Vollgas und dann drunter ging es eben darum, dass man sich für die Europameisterschaft qualifizieren möchte. Und dann viel, ich würde vermuten auch wegen des Backlashes, den es schon vorher bei Social Media gab, den Verantwortlichen auf, dass aufgrund der deutschen Historie und auch mit dem Gegner der Niederlande, das vielleicht nicht die glücklichste Wortwahl ist. Und dann hat man das umgeändert in Volley. Ja, was halt überhaupt gar keinen mehr ergeben hat. Also eigentlich ja ein ganz, ganz nettes Gedankenexperiment. Was kann man auf Vollgas noch machen, was irgendwie einen Sinn ergibt. Auf Volley wäre ich persönlich nicht gekommen, aber wahrscheinlich hatte man auch nicht so viel Zeit. Aber es wurde quasi in letzter Sekunde abgeändert. Und ja, es treibt halt so eine Entwicklung dieser gesponserten Agentur, Choreos, die sowieso schon das Ad Absorbent führt, für was eine Choreo eigentlich steht, treibt es halt noch mal auf die Spitze, dass man sich erst für einen Slogan entscheidet, der wirklich dämlich ist. Diese ganzen Ein-Wort-Slogans sind ja sowieso, also was soll das eigentlich? Dann fällt es einem doch auf und dann fällt einem nichts anderes ein, als da draus Volley zu machen.
Also, ja gut. Klar, ich würde fast behaupten, ohne jetzt den Fan-Club-Nationalmannschaft powered by zu sehr in Schutz nehmen zu wollen, aus Vollgas darf die Schölle wahrscheinlich nichts anderes mehr machen, als Volley. Und sie haben den, glaube ich, größeren Skandal abgewendet, mit dieser dann am Ende natürlich sehr peinlichen Choreo. Aber schon okay, dass man das dann so gemacht hat. Das muss einem natürlich idealerweise deutlich früher auffallen. Also nicht irgendwie eine Stunde vor dem Spiel, sondern in den Tagen und Wochen der Vorbereitung, dass man da vielleicht was Unverfängliches wählen sollte.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Ich finde, weil du das Thema mit der Blase angesprochen hast und ob die Platz sind, irgendwann muss doch mal gut sein. Ich bin da ehrlich gesagt nicht so davon überzeugt, weil das Modell grundsätzlich funktioniert ja weiter. Also hier bei mir vor der Tür gibt es Manchester United, die seit Jahren nicht mehr um Titel mitspielen, die jetzt die Saison in der Europa League spielen. Die möglicherweise, wenn sie so weiter spielen wie diese Saison, jetzt komplett aus dem internationalen Wettbewerb fliegen. Und trotzdem ist das einer der umsatzstärksten Vereine der Welt. Ist immer noch einer der umsatzstärksten Vereine der Welt. Das Stadion ist immer voll. Möglicherweise nicht mehr mit den Fans, die vor 10, 15, 20 Jahren gekommen sind, sondern mit anderen Fans, mit Fans, die dann halt auch nicht mehr unbedingt aus Manchester oder aus England kommen, sondern halt eben aus Asien zum Beispiel. Also ich glaube, oder fürchte, dass das schon noch eine Weile so funktionieren wird. Vielleicht nicht mehr so, wie man sich das als Fußballfan wünscht. Aber dass die Blase so schnell platzt, das sehe ich nicht.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, teile ich diese Einschätzung so ein bisschen. Ich glaube, dass wir nicht von der Blase sprechen werden. Also es gibt schon so einzelne Indizien, wo man sehen kann, es wird zunehmend schwieriger für alle Beteiligten, noch mehr Geld aus dem Fußball rauszupressen. Wenn ich mir ansehe, wir werden jetzt eine TV-Rechtevergabe in der Bundesliga haben, wo ich sehr gespannt darauf bin, wie da am Ende die Zahlen rauskommen. Da gibt es schon einige Leute, die sagen, eine Steigerung wird eigentlich kaum möglich sein. Der Fußball ist in seiner ökonomischen Struktur auf eine Umsatzsteigerung hin ausgelegt. Die deutschen Vereine wirtschaften zwar solider als viele andere europäische Vereine und auch als sie es früher getan haben, aber dennoch ist ein gewisses Wachstum schon bei vielen notwendig, um zukünftig konkurrenzfähig zu sein, wirtschaftlich und dann auch sportlich. Das ist das nationale Problem der Bundesliga. Und gleichzeitig sehen wir jetzt in der Champions League, das ist die angedachte Champions League Reform, wo die großen Vereine sich was tolles ausgedacht haben, was für die großen Vereine ein mehr an sicheren Spitzen spielen und damit dann eben auch da höhere TV-Einnahmen generiert, da es da jetzt die mittleren und kleinen Vereine gegen auf die Barrikaden gegangen sind und gesagt haben, ne, das könnt ihr mit uns nicht machen. Und da gibt es gerade so eine Art PAD-Situation, also den Vorschlag, den die großen Vereine sich ausgedacht haben, der wird es nicht werden. Da wurde jetzt kolportiert, dass gesagt wurde, gab es jetzt neulich einen interessanten, längeren Artikel zu, ich glaube von der FAPress, bin ich mir gerade nicht ganz sicher, wurde kolportiert, dass in einer der Sitzungen gesagt wurde von einem der Vereinsvertreter eines mittelgroßen Vereins, warum zeigt uns ständig dieses Modell, wir wollen dieses Modell nicht, von dem ihr profitiert. Also sprich, da ist gerade auch nicht klar, wie kann man die Champions League so strukturieren, dass da eben auch DTV-Einnahmen und die Einnahmen generell für die Vereine steigen. Also sprich, ich glaube nicht, die Blase wird nicht platzen, aber sie wird sich weniger schnell oder vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr ausdehnen und vielleicht langsam schrumpfen. Und dann werden halt gewisse Vereine, die finanziell auf hölzernen Beinen stehen, die werden dann platzen in dem Sinne. Also die werden dann mit dieser Konsolidierung des Marktes nicht umgehen können, während halt einige wenige noch weiter dem Wettbewerb davonziehen werden. Und ich glaube, das wird dann eher die Entwicklung. Und dann hast du eben eine noch deutlichere Zwei-Klassengesellschaft als jetzt schon im Fußball. Und dann wird es auch die hohen Ablösen geben. Aber die können sich halt wirklich nur noch 15 Vereine leisten. Und alle anderen haben wahrscheinlich schon viel größere Probleme, überhaupt den Regelbetrieb aufrechtzuerhalten.
Ja, aber das ist ja jetzt schon so, dass ich die exorbitant hohen Ablösesummen ja auch jetzt nur einen kleiner Kreis von Vereinen leisten kann.
Ja, stimmt, stimmt. Er ist ein guter Punkt, genau, hast recht. Na ja, was machen wir jetzt? Gehen wir jetzt mit einer guten oder mit einer schlechten Stimmung aus diesem Kurzpass raus? Es wirkt alles ein bisschen dystopisch, finde ich.
Ja, es wird interessant, was jetzt noch alles passiert bis zu dieser WM in Katar. Das, glaube ich, wird so der Höhepunkt all dieser kuriosen Geschichten, die da im Moment passieren.
Um vielleicht nicht ganz so negativ gestimmt rauszugehen, kann ich zumindest aus England berichten. Die Bolton Wanderers, die spielen weiterhin, die gibt es weiterhin. Die spielen mit vielen jungen Leuten und hoffen sich sportlich zu fangen. Und dann einen Neustart in der vierten Liga neu zu starten. Bei Bury kann es ja auch durchaus eine Aussicht sein, den Verein von Null wieder aufzubauen. Und dann das Ganze ein bisschen basisdemokratischer zu gestalten. Ich glaube, viele Leute würden das sogar vorziehen, wenn man mit dem nächsten möglicherweise windigen Eigentümer landet. Fängt in der vierten Liga wieder an und steht dann vor ein paar Jahren wieder vor dem gleichen Problem. So was kann ja auch immer, als du das bei Wimbledon gesehen hast, eine Chance sein, einen Verein neu aufzubauen.
Das berühmte reinigende Gewitter. Und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen sein.
Genau, also das nur, damit wir jetzt, wie gesagt, nicht zu negativ aus der Sendung rausgehen.
Nee, gar nicht. Vor allen Dingen auch, was schön ist, auch jeden Malaga zu sehen. Der Südspanier hat sicher sowieso immer gut gelaunt. Aber die Fans kommen nach wie vor ins Stadion. Malaga war jetzt am letzten Heimspiel wieder das bestbesuchte Stadion in der zweiten Liga. Es gibt einen ganz, ganz großen Zusammenschuss zwischen Fans und dem Trainer und dem Team, weil die sich wirklich abschalten und sagen, okay, mit der Vereinsführung kann man zwar nichts anfangen, aber it is what it is. Und wir nehmen das, was wir haben, und wir wollen jetzt das Beste rausholen. Und wir feuern euch an, von der ersten bis zur letzten Minute. Und irgendwie macht diese prekäre finanzielle Situation, bewirkt dann eben auch diesen schönen Zusammenschluss auf sportlicher Ebene. Und das ist doch auch was Schönes. Die Jungs gehen am Samstag, Sonntag ins Stadion und wissen, dass sie davon 18.000, 19.000, 20.000 angefeuert werden. Egal, ob sie 80.000 verdienen oder 500.000.
Das ist allerdings wahr. Ich danke euch beiden sehr. Das hat mir großen Spaß gemacht, mal auf ein paar Vorfälle zu blicken, die jetzt hier in Deutschland gar nicht so eng begleitet wurden. Ich danke zum einen in Manchester, Hendrik Buchheister, freier Journalist und als h-Buchheister auch auf Twitter. Sehr, sehr verfolgenswert. Hendrik, danke, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Danke an Fabian Pakulat, freier Journalist, der in Malaga lebt, et Rosengartler. Wenn man dir auf Twitter folgt, dann bekommt man nämlich auch so etwas wie den OkazakiDay mit. Ich hätte das ansonsten gar nicht gesehen, wenn wir uns nicht auf Twitter folgen würden. Also kann ich auch sehr empfehlen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Folgt et Rosengartler. Fabian, danke, dass du mit dabei warst. Das freut mich. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Rasen vom Kurzpass 133. Die Kurzpässe, sie gehen jetzt wieder los. Ich weiß, so einige von euch sind ein bisschen nervös geworden, weil es nicht weiterging, aber Leute, ich musste erst warten, bis der Kindergarten hier in Bayern wieder aufgemacht hat. Das war der einzige Grund, warum es keine Kurzpässe gab. Jetzt geht's wieder los. Ich bin wieder zeitlich flexibler. Wir hören uns deswegen auch schon bald wieder. Macht's gut, bis dahin eine gute Zeit.